je vais m'installer en amérique qui
viendra voir là bas un jour destin oui
je perçois tu mens
ma chérie j'ai peine à croire que tu dis
cette lettre en amérique
de l'autre côté de l'océan j'ai été ravi
de voir que vous aviez en faire ce
qu'ils croyaient de l'allonger oublié de
regarder
il m'a peut s'envoler ont fini les
danseurs
grâce à tony j'ai l'impression d'avoir
une vie ici ce qui n'était pas vrai
avant que je rencontre
aujourd'hui je suis ça juste plus
personne comment tu prendrais toi vie
entre pays
ça me fait rire est aurait peur que je
revienne
ellis les six teams farrell je suis
ravie de faire votre connaissance
j'avais des plages à moutier c'est pas
du tout la même chose
c'était qui par elle que j'ai vu dans la
voiture c'est un très bon parti
je m'étais imaginé mener notre vie mais
tu pourrais avoir une belle vie souci
plus belle
cher tony je veux que tu saches passants
ce que je crois
je me demande si j'ai encore remplies